there are so many things i need to say
about this hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be diving into
celebrities who report eating the same
thing every day and we'll be answering
the age-old question should i do this
too but first let me tell you about my
sponsor billbar so if you're looking for
a back-to-school granola bar that
doesn't suck you've got to try these new
granola build bars it tastes like if you
were to chop up granola and like mix it
with chewy fudgy chocolate and then dip
it in white chocolate but with a mother
lode of protein we love to see it so
let's pop into one of these bad boys
look at it the white chocolate so good
[Music]
obsessed super tasty paired with a piece
of fruit or you could add it to a meal
for a quick protein boost so if you want
to try build by yourself check out the
link in the description and use my promo
code abbeysharp15 to get 15 off of your
order and you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always please feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and if you are not already
subscribed hit that subscribe button and
follow me over on tiktok and instagram
at abby's kitchen alrighty friends let's
dig in so a lot of folks myself included
thrive off of routine and structure
maybe oatmeal is your go-to breakfast
you cook tacos every tuesday night or
you feel totally lost if your local
starbucks is out of your favorite drink
i get it we are creatures of habit and
having some structure in our day can
definitely have its benefits now
according to the weight loss industry
one of these main benefits is of course
weight loss now diets for weight loss
have notoriously limited the number or
types of foods that you can eat likely
because of the benefits of something we
call sensory specific satiety now
sensory specific satiety or sss is a
decline in pleasure or desire to eat a
food that we are habituated to eating
more often the fewer options you have
and the more access that you have to
those few specific foods the less likely
you are to overeat compared to when you
give yourself access to a wider range of
palatable foods now this might work in
the short term until of course you binge
on the novel restricted foods hence why
i advocate for a non-restrictive
approach to food but we also know that
what may work for weight loss often
doesn't work for health and we've seen a
trend of celebs and influencers who are
normalizing eating the exact same thing
every single day under the guise of
health and wellness so let's take a look
at a few notable examples unfortunately
i'm married to someone that has eaten
the same thing for the last 25 years now
i have a whole video with my in-depth
thoughts on victoria beckham's diet
which you can watch right here but in
short victoria primarily subsists off of
fish steamed vegetables nuts seeds and
avocados all in the name of simplicity
discipline and being really healthy but
is that what it actually promotes
well what about kelly ripa who eats the
exact same rotations of salads and
avocado toast every single day 365 days
of the year you guys know my thoughts on
that if you were to ask me this one year
from now i will have three entirely
different meals
but it will be
the same rotation of meals for just
about a year now of course foods like
fish and veggies and nuts and seeds are
all very healthy foods in their own
right and most certainly play a role in
optimizing our nutrition but no single
food or even a handful of foods for that
matter have the ability to provide us
with all the nutrients that our body
actually needs this is precisely why i
take issue with the term like superfoods
because living exclusively off of kale
and chia seeds alone may actually result
in us feeling
less than super and we can't forget
about the infamous gen salad which has
made a huge comeback this year on tick
tock in short it's a quinoa based salad
that jennifer aniston allegedly ate
every single day when she was filming on
the set of friends and even if your
choice to eat the exact same thing every
day comes from a place of satisfaction
or enjoyment over food fear or weight
restraint we still need to be mindful of
its limitations take kylie jenner for
example if you're an avid kardashian fan
you probably are no stranger to the
infamous taco recipe that she claims
that she eats every single day i eat
shrimp tacos every day the tacos the
guac the onions mix it mix it all up
shrimp the shell
shrimpies i don't get the impression
that kylie eats fish tacos every day for
any other reason other than she just
loves fish tacos but we also know that
too much of a good thing can have its
own set of negative health implications
so is it bad to be eating the same thing
every day and how do we know when this
behavior is disordered in nature or just
what we like well it comes down to our
intention are you eating the same thing
every day for convenience and to ease
the decision fatigue or is a rigid food
rule coming from a place of control
discipline and restriction let's be
pragmatic here folks trying to come up
with a unique breakfast every day of the
week is exhausting as
most of us don't have the time energy or
even food skills to be planning and
cooking new recipes three times a day
seven days a week just gotta chop up
some cucumber it's pretty easy i don't
know i'm kind of scared so having
certain staples embedded in your week
can definitely help to streamline
grocery shopping and meal prepping and
can also free up extra mental space and
energy to invest elsewhere you know what
to expect you know what to buy you know
how to prepare it and you know that you
can get a meal on the table without much
fuss other folks with specific fitness
or sports goals may need to meet certain
macronutrient and calorie intake goals
to fuel their activity in these cases
having go-to meals or a general meal
plan might help them to fuel and recover
with more ease and less mental load we
also know that structure and consistency
with meals can be beneficial for folks
who are neurodivergent or who have adhd
as it helps to make functioning more
manageable by allowing the brain to
focus on one thing at a time without
getting overstimulated or overwhelmed by
choice so when the intention is to
actually free up mental space and
relieve you of the burden of thinking
about food all day long while still
nourishing yourself it actually can
possibly help to support food freedom on
the other hand we often see that folks
who struggle with eating disorders or
disordered eating will have specific
safe foods or meals that they stick to
every single day and rarely deviate from
this this may be because they know the
exact amount of calories that they're
getting in that meal and that that
precise amount of calories or macros
doesn't seem to cause weight gain in
folks with more orthorexic tendencies
they may perceive a particular food to
be clean or specifically healthy and may
be unwilling to test the boundaries to
collect body data on how a new food
makes them feel out of fear that they
may trigger an adverse sensation or
effect regardless of the unique
rationale folks who struggle with their
relationship with food and experience a
lot of food fear may intentionally eat
the same thing every day as a way to
feel safe and in control around food
ironically this actually tends to have
the opposite effect over time and it
serves to really reinforce our fear
around foods outside of our routine so
this is where we need to ask ourselves
about flexibility can your weekends look
different from your weekdays are some of
your meals more varied than others are
you able to enjoy takeout foods or
restaurant outings without feeling
limited or deprived and are you still
able to enjoy the foods that you love
and are satisfying to you it is
absolutely possible to maintain some
level of structure with your meals if
that's what makes sense to you while
still honoring your intuition and
desires if having structure to you is
equivalent to skipping your besties
birthday dinner because it doesn't fit
your meal plan or passing on an
impromptu ice cream night with your kids
then it's worth re-evaluating if this
routine is actually serving you or doing
you harm maintaining structure and
routine with food should never mean
forfeiting your emotional satisfaction
or social connection that we get from
food food is so much more than just
nutrients or fuel we also need to leave
space for emotional satisfaction so that
eating doesn't feel like a chore and
this really comes down to being flexible
with food do you let yourself have a
burrito at lunch if that's what you're
in the mood for even though you always
have a salad and will you eat at 11 if
you're hungry even though you don't
usually eat until noon the benefits of
diet structure are largely to just open
up space in your brain and in your life
for thoughts that don't revolve around
meticulous planning and prepping a food
but if it's causing you to do the
opposite that is feel guilt regret
longing or an obsession around food then
you know that you've gone too far
structure and flexibility need to
coexist in order to benefit our minds so
there are obviously some real negative
mental health implications
of an extreme eating regimen over time
but what about the outcomes on physical
health let's talk about the dangers of
eating too much of a good thing here's
the truth even healthy foods can become
unhealthy in excess
take for example fatty fish we love to
recommend salmon and trout as an
excellent source of protein and omega-3
fats but eating fish every single day or
even multiple times a day allowed
victoria beckham or kylie can easily
rack up our mercury intake very quickly
beyond what's considered safe and even
if we swing the pendulum in the other
direction and consume a strict raw ultra
vegan diet of just like fruits and
vegetables it can also wreak havoc on
our gut from the high amount of fiber
and fodmap foods even something as
essential to life as water can have
dangerous consequences when consumed in
excess as the kidneys can only excrete
about a liter of water per hour and
drinking much more than that can
actually be fatal plus if we're
narrowing down our food choices to a
handful of health foods or even
non-health foods like ultra-processed
foods for example we may also run the
risk of overdoing it on certain
additives like emulsifiers sweeteners
oils preservatives or sugar alcohols all
ingredients that are deemed safe in
normal amounts but possibly less optimal
when they're in one of like five foods
that you eat we also have to consider
what we are not eating when we're
limiting ourselves to a handful of foods
variety is the spice of life and it's
also key to good health so there's a few
major reasons why we know this to be
true it is very difficult to meet all of
our nutritional needs even in the
context of a generally very healthy day
even if we weren't to cut out any
specific foods or types of food groups
it would be very difficult to meet all
of your minute little micros and
antioxidants in the context of a single
day so for example we might get more
lycopene in tomatoes and more
beta-carotene in carrots and if we're
switching things up often enough over
time we will tick all the boxes think of
it like having a piece of paper with
like a bunch of little holes in them
when the paper you add on top monday
through friday is cut with the exact
same holes you're never gonna fill those
holes
you're always going to see through the
paper but if everyday's paper has
different size and shape holes in
different places eventually there'll be
no gaps on the page to see through so
this is why we want to switch things up
whenever we can the goal is not to get
everything in in one day we want to
think about the dietary pattern over
time number two now a varied diet is
also important for diversifying the
bacteria in our microbiome which we know
plays an important role for immunity
digestion heart health and even brain
health thanks to the gut brain
connection therefore limited food
variety can lead to a disruption in the
healthy balance of bacteria in the gut
which can lead to bloating indigestion
gas diarrhea or chronic constipation
dysbiosis has also been associated with
increased visceral fat and increased
risk of digestive disorders like ibs
celiac and colitis as well as an
increased risk of chronic diseases like
diabetes and heart disease so ironically
folks who are restricting their food
variety out of fear of weight gain may
actually be doing themselves a
disservice long term we also know that
not getting enough food variety can
impact the production of digestive
enzymes which can actually exacerbate or
even cause food intolerances so for
instance if you stop eating dairy cold
turkey your body essentially halts the
production of the digestive enzymes
needed to digest dairy and when you
suddenly want like a lick of your kids
ice cream bam you feel like it's so damn
hot milk was a bad choice
this is often why food elimination diets
that are not indicated can become a
self-fulfilling prophecy over time so
now you know what to look for in your
own life to determine if your eating
routine is serving you but how can we
optimize our eating for our mental and
physical health here's my tip take your
structure throw in some simple
variations and add intuition and
flexibility let's take some examples
maybe you enjoy oatmeal for breakfast
because it's easy convenient inexpensive
and keeps you full and regular great an
intuitive balanced approach to routine
might mean switching up what toppings
you add or even changing the portion
size depending on how hungry you feel
that day on the weekend when you maybe
have a little bit more time to spare
maybe you're open to an impromptu brunch
date or whipping up some eggs or
pancakes at home if lunch is always a
salad so you can get in those daily veg
think about the little ways that you can
switch up the components rather than
sticking to the same cobb salad every
day in and out you could swap the
protein to chicken chickpeas or fish and
throw in different veggies nuts seeds or
dressing based on what suits your
cravings then you just need to throw in
some flexibility for a lunch meeting
with colleagues out and you've got a
much more intuitive approach to meal
planning and prep for dinner we could
think about the plate method structure
that allows us to have a standard visual
that really helps to switch up the
components depending on what's available
and what we're interested in that day we
know we want to have a protein on the
plate so that could be chicken fish tofu
beans want a carb so like rice potatoes
pasta and whatever veggies we've got on
hand so this could end up looking like a
simple stir fry or like a pasta dish
with endless possibilities and
permutations
and of course we still want the
flexibility to have like a pizza night
or a big bowl of pasta without a
vegetable in sight in conclusion can you
eat mostly the same thing every day
without sacrificing your overall health
and nutrition well by maintaining some
loose structure and some flexibility
with food while continuing to prioritize
food variety then i would say yes you
absolutely can but it really comes down
to striking that balance between
structure and flexibility without
sacrificing overall nutrition and
emotional satisfaction from food and
trying to make those small sustainable
changes to diversify meals whenever you
can so on that note that's all that i
have for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who or what
you'd like to see me talk about next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time at abby's kitchen bye
[Music]